but you have more time for your family
though now that you're not doing that
you're just doing the Conners I do and I
get to pick up my kids sometimes or take
them to school or do they come on set
ever they do come on set they say
they're coming to see me but I have a
lot of evidence to the contrary so
they'll come when I do the Conners and
they'll run around with all the other
kids and they say they're watching the
show and then when I asked they have
like no idea what the plot was and then
when I did the talk they'd always say
like oh well what are the giveaways
today I was like will see me they're
like no no we're coming to see you and
then all of a sudden I go right then I
go into like one of my kids rooms and
there's like a new TV and a vacuum
cleaner I'm like thanks for getting it
order it and everything there's like 14
blenders in my living room
that's all my kids do that we have we
all have kids at the voice and there's
like a little like compound there and
they always say they're coming from me
but really they're coming for the sugar
that's it catering oh yeah and the
children yeah I don't even care that I'm
there food is a bag the food is a big
attraction I will not stop talking until
you subscribe to my youtube channel
that's right and I could talk a lot
seriously not gonna stop yep still here
not going anywhere I see you don't walk
away from this